tied up by Merill lost the puck to zukar who
feeds Johansson Johansson zukar Rossi together
again Rossi fires and it's deflected wide by Des
Smith to the line Damon hunt down from the point
to hold for Minnesota playing in just his sixth
game of the season D hay works out from behind
the N it got through to Smith do Haim from behind
Vancouver's net through some traffic Baldi Ericson
at capriso the trio here for the wild capriso
drops to Baldi these three were not align yet when
the teams met in Vancouver Merill fires save to
Smith big strong defenseman we split up the line
with Eric s with Baldi and capriso and they've
been together the last couple of games two- goal
game Thursday night and Vancouver's win over
Florida Johansson into the slot zuk carello cut
off by Joshua back to the line M Goan a shot tried
to play to the circle Merrill with a shot that was
blocked by laford he may have hit capriso capriso
settles it down fires and a save by to Smith last
year was the first year who was ever a plus player
in the National Hockey League was a minus 95 in
his first four seasons in the league centering
pass G scores what a Beat by toino and G with
the deflection it's one Z Minnesota closely to see
if it's potentially off Sid it comes over the line
really soft but it's the changing of sides that
makes this play it's maroon all the way across the
ice def Felino one touch that opens up the center
lane drive from gdo and what a pass from Marcus
Felino redirect from Freddy Gad babber cut him
off mcka Works away from zuk Carell tried to go
short side and gusterson with a save but they get
some here in the final minute of the period Pon
wins a stick battle on besser creates some extra
possession Matt zcell gets behind MC under John
hind
Hughes who's MCO a centering pass tried to
connect with Miller and just failed to click
Guston got a skate on that one Patterson down
low to Miller Miller in the middle b a shot and
a save by Guston be overover but Miller just
trying to draw the wild defense out to create
the room he wants to get hunt out towards him so
that B can get that one timer off laferty had it
knocked Away by bagoan Eric s on it flings it
off the end boards Works around ronic fires on
goal save to Smith pulls up he gets the shot
through traffic on to Smith and then Eric Sak
gets his own dump little commitment to getting
the puck below the goal line pucks on the net
Garland Joshua in the corner centers and bler
scores bler with the deflection out front up
and over the shoulder of gustaffson and the
conu have tied at 1-1 that one looks close
too Joshua driveing the middle picks this
up backhand feed to the front Bluer able
to adjust to get the stick on it before
guson can poke that one away defense of the
wild just can't GL it close it down quick
enough and for Teddy bler that's his third
of the Season good stick there by Johansson
zuk carello back to Johansson to H do fires
and that went just wide zarell to Johansson
and a save by Smith Damon hunt here coming
through the slot missing the net but again
that's the with it along the wall for Minnesota
back in behind for Baldi Baldi escapes theor off
centers and cis's redirect went just wide from
zadorov that led to all that in the wild off a
psycho plate by far his two biggest minute
games since coming to Minnesota Cole with
a shot to Ed and a save by Guston a chance for
Vancouver point shot from Ian Cole tipped out
front from Patterson but gusson tracking that
one cleanly nice read and then stepped there
at the Blue Line Pon thought he was going to be
able to nonchalantly carry that one in forced
to make a play pass it to nobody here's Miller
in and a save by Guston change the wild try to
get the D out there they're sitting back or
sitting up a little bit JT Miller hiding at
the Blue Line gets the Outlet pass and he tries
to go under the pad of Philip guson quick little
shot good pressure by Hartman creates
a loose Puck Eric s out of the box on
the Breakaway couldn't get a shot away
penalty coming against Vancouver Eric
s just out of the box takes
the slash Minnesota the man
advantage to the line zuk Carell halfway
through the power play zuk Carell looking
waiting ericon short side save to Smith a
couple chances to clear failed gagoski with
12 in the power play Johansson down low
a centering pass is covered by to Smith
knck gets set up on the power play who's me
go down low besser and Guston makes it to
sa and sends it would have been all the way down
and hit a linesman skate it deflects right to
Felino Felino short-handed has it poke checked
Away by the Smith this led to the Marcus Felino
CH short-handed favor with the clear linesman
right in front of me I appreciate him blocking
me from taking that one Marcus Felino power move
to the net second chance too as the puck there
moves to Center and dumps it in took a hit from
Json after doing so Cole with a miscommunication
Capri off to Eric s got a pad Sav by to Smith
capriso coming out of the corner finding Eric
s Patterson spins away from Rossi another
penalty coming against Minnesota Guston
has to make a close range save the
knock win this one however Hughes with
it and Guston again forced to smother bagoan
with it FES the shot goes to Baldi into the
corner capr off centers for gagasi it's
loose and to Smith able to cover wild
reload they're able to keep it in the zone
Baldi from up top player we saw earlier in
the game capris off looking for gagoski out
front that one gets through the paths of the
Smith boy that was sitting there
gasing H circles away from gdo still with the puck
gives to Garland tries to cut through the slot
and Guston covers and he goes drives wide here
takes it I think he's got some room five hole as
gusers zuk Carell in against the Smith and he
scores oh play look at that it's where that
goal sck turns regain possession hin switches
his order of Shooters and goes to Matt boldy
second and a save by the Smith but the Smith
just goes down number he was down before baly
shot Miller swings wide stay on the back
hand and gusterson knocks it down with a
glove and a sa by Guston and
it's another shootout win for the
wild
w